and so in diving into how other how
people use architecture I got really
fascinated by the fact that you know
it's easy to take for granted that
you're supposed to use doors to get from
one room to the next you're supposed to
go down a corridor to make it through a
building you're meant to use the streets
outside to get from one building to the
next but burglars find a way of
deliberately avoiding doors they'll cut
a hole through a wall
they might even avoid the wall and cut a
hole through the floor or the ceiling
they might avoid floors and ceilings and
cut through roofs or come up from the
sewer network beneath the city in an
example that I'll come back to in in in
a few minutes but so this relationship
to architecture is one in which I
suppose you could describe it almost as
a kind of topological relationship in
that it's a more engaged
three-dimensional interaction with
architectural space than the ones that
we limit ourselves to I'll speak for
myself the one that I limit myself to as
a law-abiding user of architecture
you know I follow what the architects
laid out for me by going through doors
I don't crawl through windows very often
and I tend not to use a concrete coring
machine to get to the next floor but
this is something that burglars will do
so a couple just quick examples that I
go into more length in the book you know
this can be either an ingenious act of
almost revelatory architectural
short-circuiting such as a guy this
individual named Bill Mason who at one
point was robbing a mob connected hotel
outside Cleveland which sounds like a
good idea and he he wanted to get into
the cash room but it was heavily guarded
so he had a realization that the way the
hotel was built he can in fact just
break into the hotel room next to the
office go into the closet cut a hole
through the drywall no one's put they're
not protecting the walls from within go
into the cash room steal whatever he
wanted to and then leave out of a door
of his own making as he referred to it
like a kind of pop-up entry waste
through through the world of
architecture those examples are
obviously there are many examples like
that in the in the world of architecture
as the book goes into or the world of
burglary but then on the flip side of
that there are people who in trying to
second-guess architecture it doesn't go
quite as well so one example was a this
kid who I still kind of feel bad for but
in the City of Milwaukee Wisconsin
decided in the middle of the night to
break into a veterinarian's office but
instead of going through the front door
which would have been too easy or even
going through the window which made too
much sense he went up to the roof cut a
hole into the HVAC system and then
proceeded to remove all of his clothing
I think under the impression that that
would reduce friction and slip into the
air-conditioning duct in order to get
some painkillers down below but in this
kind of you know in the book I compared
to a surreal nudists remake of die hard
and in his nudity yeah he get got
trapped away was he had a flashlight in
one hand and a hammer in the other and
in trying to get out of the air duct I
was making so much noise that when the
people showed up six or seven hours
later they actually thought an animal
had been trapped inside the air duct and
he had to be removed by the fire
department but so those kinds of
examples are pretty shockingly common
you find that burglars and trying to
rethink the notion of a getaway there's
one great example in New Zealand where
somebody broke into a house and then it
tried to get away by actually going
further into the house so he crawled up
into the ceiling and then somewhat
incredibly his toe was sticking out of
the ceiling insulation and the police
spotted this body part from nowhere
coming down from the ceiling tiles and
pulled him down and arrested him there
are a lot of examples of people trying
to hide inside walls to get away to cut
their way deeper and deeper into
buildings and have to call the call
9-1-1 themselves in order to get out so
what I'm getting at is that for every
intelligent or exciting misuse of
architecture there are these weird sort
of dead-end misuses of architecture that
don't quite go as planned
you
[Music]